let's commence my spirit welcome back to
everyday I with some there we don't
really know what's up with the
whistleblower yet the mainland Warren
see I think we're gonna visit the female
ward this is a long ass do see I'm not
complaining but it's a lot more epic
than I thought oh I am I am
had a lamb scam is so [ __ ] epic man
let's keep going you never know what you
can find this place
oh no it's not more people I hate people
well that's him they've repented that's
wonderful so this is not a prequel I
shouldn't realize long ago though okay
let's go
now maybe we should yeah yeah the
elevators exit Oh God
how do I know no I don't want to go in
there I hated that place that place is
horrible
well my guys leg must be like broken in
ten places why can't we go out here he
doesn't even want to try
I got a missing something Oh yep I don't
like the sound of that killing people
awesome
I'll just be on my way then
I had a lot of fun here batteries by the
monix gone who Chango don't see Elena
suckas
oh my guy yes no no no no no no no no no
no no no no please no yeah yeah for sure
I'm a little little piggy and I'm lost
don't know how to deal with that oh this
mirror do the optic quality on this DLC
you like it has for feeling loved it I
live it it's very good sound jack man
love it we're skyping hallelujah praise
the love ha ha thank God thank you oh my
god I don't know if I'll ever recover
from this place but it leaves now I can
document it and upload it you boy oh
yeah this is where we started oh my god
the feels the feels do you hear that
chair is where I got scared the first
time in Antony's ah it's all coming back
to me now we're almost out of this place
documents better bring all of them
everyone shall know about don't try to
I'm at nothing sorry
hate to break the mood it has to be over
right like no [ __ ] way they can can't
keep these online this is it man I look
good Jesus
well
good times this is all I gots a good
[ __ ] times ten out of ten mr. Park ah
oh no no we came so far why does he want
to kill me so much
he's my favorite
we let it out oh now he's tasty then
we're a [ __ ] tank man the squares like
brofist come on man you can do it
one step for boats one step for the bro
a lot of steps actually can you smell
that pollution
Jesus
freedom [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
freedom I feel like this is too sweet to
be true you know after all the [ __ ] we
went through that's our car too
around the car the other guys car
whatever we're gonna take his car oh it
took his car to escape cuz he died by
the Nazis that's bad
shouldn't we realize isn't even like
there's someone there oh god no no no no
no no no no no who the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] it not good enough for 200
no Drive
for the love of GERD read
well that's pretty good holy [ __ ] Wow
the [ __ ] did he do that you press that
button there's no going back mr. Park
there's enough hard evidence in that
video file that make a world of [ __ ] for
our friends at Murkoff there's a mess of
a life and we've done everything in our
power and virulence but our enemies are
twitching and malicious corporate
paranoiacs with resources you're too
moral to imagine you might be the only
target anyone you care about your wife
your child there'll be nothing to make
off the ways to hurt you I need you to
understand the bridge you're crossing
here you will do irrevocable damage to
the company you might even get close to
something like justice but once you
click upload a lot is over everyone you
love is [ __ ] but it's the right thing
to do is hurting Murkoff worth that much
do
I mean it's pretty obvious we don't even
know about his children or whatever
press left mouse button so I actually
have to do it make it a crack no it's
[ __ ] I was really good I'd really
really Reno it's way better than I
expected I think this is even better
than the actual main game I don't know
that was a really good deal see like it
did what you wanted to do it's hard to
describe it it's pretty damn awesome it
really did have a Bioshock feel to it I
know I said that a lot Bay and I like
that you know I think if if outlast and
Bioshock had a baby I would be a happy
father I guess I think that would be
something really cool
a bit [ __ ] more horror take on Bioshock
or something like that
but yeah so this is a great DLC really
enjoyed it
they really go fallout like it's really
hard to play I usually expect a DLC
something that you could finish in one
sitting but that's if you finish this
game in one setting you're pretty badass
in my opinion for me it just gets too
much with all the horror so but that was
like my only critique with outlets and I
think it'll be my only critique of this
game because I it gets too much to play
like I know they have some moments where
it's more chill but you never feel safe
in this game ever is that a good thing
it's not a bad thing I don't know for me
it gets too much I have to stop playing
and stuff like that
maybe for other love it I don't know but
I still love this DLC I thought it was
really great I want to thank you boys
for watching it with me I had a lot of
fun playing it I said you can probably
tell and hopefully I'll be back from
Japan soon I don't know how in the
future will work but please do leave a
like if you enjoy watching this series I
do appreciate it a lot
and there's the kiss for you breakfast